- All right, let's close out
this hour with one last story
I hope will bring joy to your day.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
A Chicago artist got tired
of seeing potholes on the
streets of his neighborhood
so he came up with a
very creative solution,
mosaic arts.
Super cool.
Not only are mosaics long-lasting,
his works are truly beautiful.
Now he fills the potholes around
the world with his tiling.
Designing everything from animals to food,
to recreations of masterpieces
hanging at the Art Institute of Chicago.
He's incredible.
So we have him on the line right now.
Let's say hi to Bachor
watching on NBC Chicago
at three, everybody.
(audience cheering and applauding)
What's up, Bachor!?
- Hey, Kelly.
- You are super gifted, man.
It's such a rad idea.
How did you come up with the idea?
- Well, it all started with
an initial trip to Italy
back in the late 1990s.
I kind of fell in love with ancient art
or ancient ruins and whatnot.
And so when you do that,
you run across ancient mosaics.
And ancient mosaics are
made with marble and glass
and marble and glass don't fade.
So the art looks the way the
artist intended 2000 years ago.
And so that thought to this
day kind of drives my artwork.
So currently, I do fine art,
stuff that I sell on my website
and I do commissions and whatnot
but it was really the
pothole art that caught fire.
And that was back in May of 2013.
There were bad, bad potholes in Chicago
that particular year,
and especially on our street.
And there was one stubborn
pothole in front of our house
that would get fixed
and then three months later
the asphalt will pop out
and they'd have to get
fixed again and whatnot.
And so I started thinking
the juxtaposition
of this art form I was so passionate about
that was so durable
with this unsolvable problem
outside of our house.
And so what I decided to do one night,
and I did it at night
because I wasn't sure
if it was legal or not,
is I went out there with some concrete
and a piece of mosaic art
and I fixed that pothole.
And so what happened from there
is that it just kind of blew up.
People love them.
I ended up doing,
I've done over a hundred
now at this point.
Most of them are in Chicago
but a lot of 'em are around the country.
And there's even a couple international,
in like internationally
and like Finland and Italy.
- That's so cool.
And just helping your city look cooler.
It's like you're not
just filling the pothole,
you're creating something beautiful too
in in the same moment.
Thank you so much, Bachor.
I'm liking your post right now.
- [Bachor] Course, thank you.
- And that's not all my man.
Our season long partner
Pilot pen makers G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to honor truly unstoppable
and creative people just like you, sir.
So, they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Whoa!
That's unexpected.
Thank you.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- [Bachor] That never happens.
Thank you.
- [Kelly] Thank you so much, Bachor.
- [Bachor] Thank you so much.
- Thank you to all our guests this hour.
Bryan Cranston, Rita
Wilson, Chef Kady Chen.
Ya have a great day
and if it's not,
try and change it.